il n'y a pas si longtemps j'ai dû interviewer un
archéologue américain en anglais donc pour un
projet documentaire documentaire qui va sortir
là dans pas longtemps je ferai l'annonce de la
sortie sur instagram en priorité donc n'hésitez
pas à me suivre sur instagram pour être tenu au
courant de cette sortie (GROSTRUC) je suis allée à
cette interview en grosse confiance parce que
je partais du principe que comme j'ai vécu un an
à londres oui j'ai vécu un temps à londres quand
j'étais très jeune bah c'est bon c'était acquis
quoi l'anglais c'était super facile ce voyage là à
londres sa date de 2009 autant vous dire un paquet
d'années et donc quand je suis arrivée devant ce
scientifique je n'ai pas perdu mes moyens mais c'était vraiment pas agréable c'était pas
fluide pour moi en tout cas je vous raconte
ça aujourd'hui parce que j'ai été contactée la
dernièrement par Cambly qui sponsorise aujourd'hui
la vidéo Cambly c'est une application qui permet
de trouver des cours d'anglais avec des tuteurs
natifs anglophones et donc ça permet de se
préparer à tenir une conversation préparer un
entretien d'embauche préparer des examens etc
pour que vous puissiez vous faire une idée
plus précise de ce qu'est Cambly et des cours qui
sont proposés et bien rien de tel je pense qu'un
court extrait de ce que moi j'ai vécu ce matin
très sincèrement j'aurais aimé avoir connaissance
de cette application pour préparer mon travail et
cette interview. Comment ça se passe très
concrètement Cambly ? c'est très simple il
vous suffit d'aller sur la page d'accueil
vous avez les informations de base sur les
profs leur expérience il est possible de
trouver un tuteur spécifique dans presque
toutes les matières j'en ai trouvé en science
en marketing en médical et même j'ai trouvé
un anthropologue c'est vous dire. Pour
les timides je sais que vous êtes là,
pas d'inquiétude les profs sont là pour vous
aider dans vos projets et pas que professionnels
d'ailleurs si vous voulez voyager tout simplement
et vous familiariser avec l'anglais avant le
départ franchement n'hésitez pas à vous offrir
15 30 minutes une heure de leçon avec Cambly
et donc pour cal j'ai évidemment une petite
promo pour vous avec le code passesauvage60
vous pouvez faire un cours gratuit de 15 minutes
et avoir 60 % de réduction sur les abonnements 12
mois. Je vous conseille vraiment d'essayer
pour en profiter il vous suffit de cliquer
sur le lien qui est là dans la description juste
sous la vidéo de vous créer un compte et ensuite
et bien de trouver un prof sur Cambly c'est tout
et maintenant on enchaîne avec la vidéo du jour
D’où viennent les juifs d’Europe de l’Est
? Sont-ils des descendants d’Hébreux exilés
de force d’Israël ou des convertis ? Cette
question qui vous paraît peut-être anecdotique
est pourtant au cœur de controverses
acharnées entre historiens israéliens.
Et si je vous dis que les Khazars, un brave peuple
de cavaliers nomades du Moyen-âge a peut-être
la réponse… Au premier abord ça a pas l’air
fantastique hein, et pourtant ces fameux Khazars,
du fin fond de leurs steppes russes médiévales,
continuent de faire couler énormément d’encre
en Israël. Leur conversion à la religion juive
il y a bientôt 1300 ans gène beaucoup de monde
et va même jusqu’à remettre en question une
grande partie du récit national israélien.
Aujourd’hui je vous propose de vous expliquer les
termes d’un débat ultra-sensible. On va présenter
plusieurs points de vue, et bien sûr on ne
va apporter aucune réponse définitive dans
cette vidéo. Je tiens quand même à préciser que
tous les développements qui suivent ne sont pas
mon avis personnel, mais celui des auteurs
sur lesquels je m’appuie. Vous trouverez
d’ailleurs tous les livres et articles
consultés en description sous la vidéo.
Avant de parler des Khazars, il faut
revenir sur le récit traditionnellement
admis par les historiens du judaïsme.
L’historiographie dominante en Israël
établit que tous les juifs d’Europe et du bassin
méditerranéen sont des descendants des Hébreux,
le peuple antique qui a fondé la religion
juive. Subissant différentes invasions,
ils auraient été exilés de force
par des conquérants successifs,
en particulier l’empereur romain Titus. Cet
empereur a fait détruire le Second Temple de
Jérusalem en 70 ap. J.-C., suite à une grande
révolte, et aurait, pour marquer son triomphe,
réduit en esclavage tous les Hébreux. Vendus
et dispersés dans tout l’Empire, ils auraient
toutefois conservé une identité commune, faisant
d’eux un peuple juif en exil, une diaspora.
Car le dogme juif orthodoxe n’envisage pas que
des populations aient pu se convertir au judaïsme.
Contrairement au christianisme ou à l’Islam qui se
veulent des religions universelles et cherchent à
se répandre, le message du judaïsme ne s’adresse
normalement qu’aux Hébreux et leurs descendants.
Le dieu unique est censé avoir fait une alliance
avec eux, et leur avoir promis une terre en
échange de leur fidélité. Selon ce principe,
seuls les descendants des Hébreux peuvent donc
pratiquer la religion juive, et revendiquer leur
terre. Tous les juifs du monde seraient donc un
seul et même peuple. Les différences entre juifs,
ashkénazes d’Europe de l’Est, séfarades d’Espagne
et du Maghreb ou mizrahims du Moyen-Orient, ne
seraient donc que des variations superficielles,
conséquences de nombreux siècles d’exil.
Voilà pour ce qui est du récit historique
tel qu’il est le plus souvent raconté. Mais
ce récit a aussi eu des débouchés politiques.
Le mouvement sioniste est un élan commencé au
XIXe siècle pour fonder un foyer national juif
dans la Palestine sous domination britannique,
et il s’est basé sur tout ce qu’on vient de
dire. Les lointains descendants d’exilés
Hébreux auraient, d’après leur histoire,
des droits légitimes pour retourner sur les terres
de leurs ancêtres, la terre d’Israël. La migration
des juifs du monde entier vers ce nouvel
Etat serait donc un juste retour des choses,
en même temps que l’accomplissement d’un destin
biblique. C’est d’ailleurs toujours le principe
qui préside à l’immigration en Israël. Si une
personne peut attester d’une ascendance juive,
elle est autorisée à venir s’installer
dans le pays, ça s’appelle l’Alyah.
Parmi ces juifs candidats au retour en
Israël, les plus nombreux sont les ashkénazes,
c’est-à-dire ceux qui vivent en Europe
de l’Est et parlent la langue yiddish,
ceux qui sont au cœur du débat historique qu’on
explique aujourd’hui. On estime qu’ils étaient
près de 9 millions avant le génocide perpétré
par les nazis pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Les juifs ashkénazes, sont réputés avoir migré
vers l’Est de l’Europe au cours du Moyen-âge,
en provenance de l’ouest du continent et en
particulier d’Allemagne, après avoir transité par
Rome. Même si cette émigration d’origine allemande
n’est pas spécialement documentée par les textes,
la présence de vocabulaire majoritairement
allemand dans la langue yiddish a servi de
confirmation évidente à cette théorie.
Mais il y a aussi une autre théorie sur
l’origine des juifs ashkénazes, et c’est
là qu’interviennent nos fameux Khazars.
Les Khazars sont un peuple turco-mongol d’Asie
centrale, qui migre au sud du Caucase vers le
Ve siècle de notre ère. Ils étendent au VIIe
siècle leur influence au nord des montagnes,
sur tout l’espace entre la mer Noire et la mer
Caspienne, dans le sud de la Russie actuelle.
Les archéologues les ont identifiés comme la
culture « saltovo-mayaki », reconnaissable
à son artisanat du métal, les boucles de
ceintures et harnais de chevaux ouvragés
en sont les artefacts caractéristiques.
Plus qu’un Etat sédentaire et centralisé,
l’Empire khazar c’est plutôt un pouvoir qui
contrôle une partie des routes de la soie et
qui prélève une part des richesses transitant
par son territoire. Les Khazars apportent aussi
à ce commerce leur savoir-faire, notamment dans la
production de fourrures ou la capture d’esclaves.
Une nébuleuse de peuples soumis plus ou moins
sédentaires leur paye tribut, et se range ainsi
sous la protection des cavaliers khazars.
Jusque-là, rien de bien exceptionnel,
des dizaines d’autres royaumes de ce genre
ont vu le jour en Eurasie durant ces trois
derniers millénaires. Seulement les Khazars au
VIIIe siècle, contrairement à tous les autres,
adoptent le judaïsme comme religion d’Etat.
Vers 740, c’est le roi khazar Boulan qui se
convertit le premier au judaïsme. Boulan aurait
dit-on convié les représentants des trois grands
monothéismes à sa cour pour faire son choix et
tranché en faveur de la plus ancienne et donc plus
respectable des trois religions, le judaïsme. Mais
les considérations politiques n’ont pas dû être
totalement étrangères à sa décision. En adoptant
le christianisme ou l’islam, le royaume khazar se
serait immanquablement retrouvé inféodé à l’un
de ses deux voisins : l’empereur de Byzance ou
le calife de Damas. Ces deux souverains, chrétien
et musulman, cherchaient à étendre leur domination
dans la région habitée par les Khazars, notamment
en diffusant leurs religions parmi la population.
Le judaïsme fournit donc une opportunité
remarquable, une troisième voie qui place
à égalité les Khazars avec ses deux rivaux.
Cette conversion officielle d’un Etat entier
à la religion juive est un exemple unique dans
l’Histoire. Toutefois ce bouleversement religieux
n’a pas forcément été accepté par la majorité
de la population. Il subsiste dans le royaume
khazar une grande hétérogénéité religieuse. Le
géographe arabe Al-Masudi écrit au Xe siècle
qu’il y a dans la capitale khazare sept juges
: deux pour les juifs, deux pour les musulmans,
deux pour les chrétiens et un pour les païens,
jugeant d’après les lois de chaque religion. Les
sources médiévales qui parlent des Khazars
se contredisent d’ailleurs sur l’importance
de la conversion, certaines affirment que
tous les Khazars sont juifs, d’autres, que
seule une minorité avait adopté cette religion.
Quoi qu’il en soit, cet épisode de la conversion
des Khazars au judaïsme a fait émerger une seconde
hypothèse historique. Il se pourrait bien que les
juifs ashkénazes ne soient pas des Hébreux exilés
à Rome, puis en Allemagne, et enfin en Europe de
l’Est, mais plutôt des descendants de Khazars.
Certains Khazars auraient migré progressivement
vers l’Europe centrale, peut-être poussés par
les invasions mongoles, mais d’autres seraient
restés sur leurs terres et formeraient les
communautés juives actuelles du Caucase.
Cette théorie, esquissée dès le XIXe siècle,
a été formalisée et popularisée par l’ouvrage
la Treizième Tribu, d’Arthur Koestler, paru
en 1976. Elle vient complètement remettre en
question les origines des juifs ashkénazes, et une
partie de l’argumentaire historique du sionisme.
La théorie de l’origine khazare a été vivement
critiquée. Plusieurs historiens se sont attachés
à montrer que les sources médiévales qui parlent
de la conversion des Khazars sont problématiques.
Parmi eux, Shaul Stampfer, qui était professeur à
l’Université Hébraïque de Jérusalem, a publié en
2013 un article qui conteste toutes les données
sur lesquelles se basent l’hypothèse khazare.
Dans « Did the Khazars Convert to Judaism ? »,
Stampfer critique en particulier la principale
source à la disposition des historiens. Il s’agit
d’une lettre du roi khazar en personne, un certain
Joseph, qui répond à une missive envoyée par un
juif espagnol au Xe siècle. Hasdaï ibn-Shafrut,
médecin et conseiller juif à la cour du calife
de Cordoue, a en effet appris qu’un royaume juif
existait loin à l’est, et décide d’en savoir
plus. Il envoie vraisemblablement deux lettres,
la première ne dépasse pas Constantinople,
mais la deuxième parvient jusqu’au roi Joseph.
La réponse du roi khazar qui nous est
connue grâce à des copies ultérieures,
raconte alors la conversion de son peuple :
La suite du récit décrit le pays et ses coutumes.
Et c’est justement ce qui fait dire à Stampfer,
que la lettre n’a pas été écrite par le roi. Il
juge en effet ce souverain très mal renseigné,
ne citant pas les grandes villes de son royaume,
ne semblant pas connaître beaucoup de détails sur
ses habitants ou ses frontières. Ces imprécisions
que certains avaient attribuées à l’altération du
recopiage ou à des effets de style, disqualifient
complètement le document d’après Stampfer.
Les autres textes analysés par Stampfer,
les sources des géographes arabes notamment,
sont tous également rejetés. En étudiant le
récit de voyage d’ibn Fadlan qui annonce au
Xe siècle que « les Khazars et leur roi sont
tous juifs », Stampfer conclut qu’il a dû se
tromper ou qu’il a recopié sur quelqu’un qui
s’est trompé. Il est vrai que certains auteurs
du Moyen-âge n’avaient pas réellement voyagé
dans les pays qu’ils décrivaient et qu’ils
pouvaient parfois colporter des rumeurs.
On pourrait toutefois opposer à Stampfer
que les informations que les marchands ont
rapporté pendant plusieurs siècles, ou
les guerres répétées entre les Khazars
et le califat musulman seraient peut-être
venues à bout de ces rumeurs. Mais pour lui,
la conversion n’a tout simplement pas eu lieu :
Un avis très tranché et donc très favorable aux
positions sionistes. S’il n’y pas eu
de conversion, c’est donc qu’il y a
bien eu un exil des Hébreux. Mais
le débat est loin d’être terminé.
Le vaste mouvement du post-sionisme est à
contre-courant de ce récit national juif
israélien. Développé au sein des universités
du pays depuis les années 1990, par ceux que
l’on a nommé les « Nouveaux historiens
israéliens », le post-sionisme questionne
les fondements de la nation israélienne. L’un de
ses représentants les plus connus aujourd’hui est
Shlomo Sand. Extrêmement critique sur la politique
israélienne actuelle, il dénonce la colonisation
des Territoires palestiniens, le militarisme, la
conception ethnocentrique de la citoyenneté, etc.
Les travaux des « nouveaux historiens » ont
surtout porté sur l’Etat d’Israël depuis sa
création en 1948, mais Shlomo Sand s’est
aussi intéressé à l’histoire ancienne. Et
en particulier aux Khazars, qui ont le droit à
un long passage de son best-seller : Comment le
peuple juif fut inventé. Sand y reprend la thèse
d’Arthur Koestler sur l’origine des ashkénazes,
qui seraient les descendants des Khazars.
Mais Shlomo Sand remonte aussi plus loin.
Sand affirme notamment que l’exil antique des
Hébreux, dont on a parlé en début de vidéo,
est une invention qui sert à masquer que le
judaïsme s’est propagé majoritairement par
conversion. En effet les traces historiques d’un
tel exil, on parle nécessairement de dizaines de
milliers de personnes déracinées, sont difficiles
à mettre en évidence d’après lui. Il y a bien-sûr
Flavius Josèphe, historien romain juif de Judée
qui mentionne 97 000 prisonniers lors de la prise
de Jérusalem par les Romains, mais il parle
aussi d’un million de morts lors de l’assaut,
ce qui paraît totalement excessif. Aujourd’hui,
les historiens semblent plutôt s’accorder sur
une population de 60 000 habitants à
Jérusalem à l’époque. Flavius Josèphe
a donc très probablement exagéré les chiffres
pour illustrer la cruauté des légions romaines.
Il y a donc eu de nombreuses victimes et peut-être
plusieurs milliers de prisonniers, mais sans doute
pas de là à exiler tous les Hébreux. Shlomo
Sand rappelle pour sa part que les Romains
n’ont jamais pratiqué la déportation de tout un
peuple. D’ailleurs pour un empire qui cherche à
percevoir l’impôt sur des terres cultivées, vider
une province de sa population n’est absolument
pas rentable. Cela aurait de toute façon
demandé des moyens logistiques hors de portée
des Romains de l’Antiquité. Et puis une autre
grande révolte a lieu en Judée en 135 ap. J.-C.,
ce qui montrerait bien que les habitants sont
toujours sur place soixante-cinq ans plus tard.
Et là encore, les historiens romains mentionnent
bien une répression implacable, mais pas d’exil.
La question qui suit est dès lors inévitable : si
la Judée ne s’est jamais vidée de ses habitants,
qu’est devenue la majorité des Hébreux qui
serait toujours restée sur ses terres ?
Shlomo Sand estime que l’immense majorité d’entre
eux s’est lentement convertie à l’islam. Les
conquérants musulmans appliquaient en effet
un impôt aux « gens du Livre » (les dhimmis),
c’est-à-dire aux pratiquants des autres
religions monothéistes. Cet impôt avait un
double effet sur ceux qui le payaient : il leur
faisait reconnaître la supériorité du pouvoir
musulman et les incitait à embrasser l’islam pour
ne plus le payer. On le sait, les incitations
financières sont souvent plus efficaces que
les interdictions catégoriques. En effet,
au fil des siècles, beaucoup de chrétiens
et juifs résidant dans les Etats musulmans
ont adopté la religion musulmane. Sand écrit :
Un retournement total du récit qu’on a présenté
au début. Les descendants des Hébreux seraient
en réalité… les Palestiniens ! De quoi déplaire
à pas mal de monde en Israël. Surtout
quand cette théorie est reprise par les
nationalistes palestiniens pour contester
jusqu’à l’existence de l’Etat israélien.
On le voit cette histoire a des conséquences
politiques particulièrement sensibles. Dans
une région du Moyen-Orient en conflit depuis
plus de soixante-dix ans, la conversion ou non
d’un peuple nomade au Moyen-âge prend des
allures de bombe identitaire et politique.
L’affaire khazare permet de bien comprendre la
spécificité de la démarche historique et le statut
problématique qu’y occupe la vérité objective. Les
sources sont soumises à interprétation et souvent
contestables. Avec un tel enjeu idéologique,
on a tendance de part et d’autre à tordre le
récit dans le sens qui nous arrange. Chaque
publication déclenche son lot de réfutations,
elles-mêmes réfutées par des études postérieures.
On dénonce les manquements de ses adversaires qui
ignorent des sources, interprètent trop
largement des passages évasifs, etc.
Et d’autres disciplines se sont invitées dans
le débat. La génétique par exemple, a ajouté
son grain de sel. Généralement considérée comme
une science aux résultats indiscutables, elle
peut pourtant orienter les résultats en fonction
des échantillons choisis. L’étude d’Eran Elhaik,
publiée en 2012 dans Genome Biology[4] et qui
allait dans le sens de l’hypothèse khazare,
a par exemple été décriée pour ne porter
que sur un petit nombre d’individus. La
linguistique a aussi participé au débat. Le
linguiste israélien Paul Wexler affirme que
la base de la langue yiddish, celle parlée par les
ashkénazes, n’est pas l’allemand, mais le slave,
ce que d’autres contestent en retour.
La recherche historique en Israël est,
vous l’avez compris, un sujet extrêmement
inflammable. Tout le monde s’accuse de faire
de la propagande. Et parfois ça finit même devant
les tribunaux. L’université d’Haïfa a par exemple
été assignée en justice en 2002 à cause du
mémoire de maîtrise de l’un de ses étudiants
dirigé par l’historien Ilan Pappé, l’un des
chefs de file des « nouveaux historiens ».
La justice a démontré que cet étudiant avait
volontairement déformé des témoignages pour
accuser l’armée israélienne d’un massacre dans
le village de Tantura pendant la guerre de 1948.
Le climat politique et idéologique est donc
tellement dégradé qu’il rend tout débat serein
extrêmement compliqué pour l’instant. En bref,
il paraît illusoire de voir prochainement un
consensus sur la question des Khazars. Mais
peut-être que ce n’est pas si important après
tout. Peu importe ce qu’ont fait les Khazars il y
a mille ans, aujourd’hui les peuples israélien et
palestinien doivent cohabiter, la majorité d’entre
eux ne demandent que ça d’ailleurs. Peut-être
qu’il faut appeler les nationalistes des deux
bords à ne pas prendre l’Histoire trop au sérieux,
et leur remémorer ce que disait Ernest Renan
dans une conférence à la Sorbonne en 1882 :